from fortune.com
people who skipped their covid vaccine
are at higher risk of traffic accidents
according to a new study
really okay uh I'm ready to see every
every meteorologist just gutted at at
this point just just fire em all we need
to get some some billionaires like Elon
Elon you bought Twitter you can buy
these outlets for much cheaper buy them
just fire everybody just just just no
more I'm I can't I can't anymore with
this what does getting vaccinated have
to do with getting into a car accident
well my guess is that they did a study
uh or a group of studies and they found
that people that hadn't been vaccinated
had gotten into more car accidents in
the past and then now they're
extrapolating in some unfounded
conclusion that it means in the future
they're also going to be a risk of it
which is insane it's inaccurate that's
my guess I haven't read the article yet
but let's find it I forgot who said this
but someone responded to this story
saying that's because all the vaccinated
people are suffering heart attacks in
their homes and not driving their cars
that's one possibility who knows I'm not
a medical doctor so
but again this is desperate propaganda
just trying to Gaslight people to push a
big Pharma product that extensively is
being used as a form of compliance for
the general public I got it I gotta say
you know as I always do talk to your
doctor about what's right for you right
don't don't get advice from podcasts I
just gotta say however if you go to your
doctor and say Doc now I haven't gotten
the vaccine am I at risk for getting
into a car accident he's gonna be like
what according to fortunate
I got another idea this is a threat to
all the unvaccinated people saying hey
you're not vaccinated you're gonna get
in a car accident here and we're gonna
make sure you're gonna take this or else
I think because how else how else could
they get so desperate how else this is
ridiculous Last Christmas I think Biden
told people you're in for a season of
death of severe death and illness and I
remember being on the show being like
that's not happening it's propaganda
it's going to be Biden in a car and he's
gonna he's gonna be like sitting like
across the street with this engine off
and he sees you leave your house
and then he speeds around Cuts you off
and then T-Bones you Dr Fountain
Fisher-Price car yeah
Biden gets out and goes
come on man get vaccinated I don't think
it would happen too late but it's
possible that a society would track
everyone that got vaccinated like the
CCP has been doing tracking people and
then start intentionally harming people
that haven't been vaccinated and then
blaming it on them not getting
vaccinated not I don't think there's any
evidence that that's happened but that
could be a move okay well to be fair
let's read what they're saying they say
if you passed on getting the covid
vaccine you might be a lot more likely
to get into a car crash or at least
those are the findings of a new study
published this month in the American
Journal of Medicine during the summer of
2021 Canadian researchers examined the
encrypted government held records of
more than 11 million adults sixteen
percent of whom hadn't received the
vaccine they found that the unvaccinated
people were 72 percent more likely to be
involved in a severe traffic crash in
which at least one person was
transported to the hospital than those
who were vaccinated that's similar to
The increased risk of car crashes for
people who with sleep apnea though only
about half of the people who abuse
alcohol research is fine
the excess risk of a car crash posed by
unvaccinated drivers exceeds the safety
gains from Modern automobile engineering
advances and also imposes risks on other
Road users the authors wrote
all right
I wouldn't be surprised if where we're
going with this is we're hereby
announcing that your driver's license
cannot be renewed unless you are up to
date on your vaccines I think they were
already doing that in some some places
like you need to prove a vaccination or
whatever but where that then brings us
is no one's allowed to drive anymore
self-driving cars only I think this
article is a self-owned they did say
that it might the headline says that it
is and then the first sentence is that
it might so they're contradicting
themselves this says they are at a
higher risk and then the first sentence
says they might be so that's a lie
they're lying in some way and then it's
exactly what I said earlier it was a
something in the past indicated that
more people that hadn't been vaccinated
got into 72 percent more car accidents
in a study that does not indicate that
in the future that will also happen that
is not an indication of that Ian stop
questioning the science I don't think
this is science hold on I can actually
break down for you why this is true it
has to do with risk I'm assuming there
are people that are more willing to take
more risk it's real simple people who
got vaccine were more likely to stay
home terrified of getting sick and
people who didn't were more likely to go
out and keep working true so what did
they find well gee look at all these yes
because people who go outside face
danger yeah I love it and now there's
going I'm telling you Christmas is
coming up and there's going to be
someone in your family who's like well
you should have went and gotten the
vaccine because now you're gonna get in
a car accident and you're gonna be like
Ma what are you talking about that makes
no sense well I was watching the MSNBC
and they said oh geez you gotta be like
oh yeah Fortune Magazine
what are you talking about News Guard
certified 100 out of 100. all right well
that's got to come down
you know I was uh I was thinking about
that Yuri besman up quote where he said
someone who's totally demoralized you
could you could tell them show them
proof that Black is Black is white and
white is white and they won't they
cannot be you know taken out of this
and I'm thinking just that that explains
it and that interviews from what 40
years ago yeah where he's talking about
demoralization it explains how you can
actually go to someone and say here is a
picture of the thing and they'll be like
nah I okay well then what do you do man
if if there are people who just like eat
this stuff up and believe it and they
lack the ability to understand nuance
what what is the end result half the
planet implodes the other half just
rebuild if you do nothing but you can
give people morale boosts great
commanders do that great artists can do
that and that'll wake people up in their
own mind you know and then they'll start
to notice their surroundings you know
this is what I was talking about with
the Washington Post thing how when you
watch a show like this we try and break
down the story we try to make sense of
it and if you read the news they just
say this garbage
the headline should literally say
ridiculous study claims people who Skip
the code of vaccine at a higher risk for
traffic accidents ignores
ignores common sense and then it could
have said right away people who were
getting the vaccine were probably more
likely to stay home and people who
didn't were probably more likely to go
out and if you go outside you're more
likely to get in a car accident story's
over have a nice day or they could have
just said hey we're desperate we're
getting being uh we're being paid by big
Pharma to chill for this just please
take it uh Gene with this news story
make you take the vaccine
well someone who's been in a few car
accidents um you know no
um look I this is exactly you all of you
guys are correct you're making a really
good points which is there are special
influences who are funding a lot of
these studies and these polls and the
things that you see that are driving
news and there's a failure from the
Legacy Media and from Outlets that are
News Guard certified to actually report
things in a way that makes sense to
people I mean it it that was the most
nonsensical thing you could you could
ever imagine every American knows
correlation is not causation but here we
are and uh you know you see something
like that and it's it's it if that
doesn't strike that headline doesn't
strike you is absolute insanity and
divorced from reality then like you you
ought to go get your head examined you
ought to go get go talk to somebody
because there's something wrong you you
aren't able to understand things clearly
they're not examined it's probably a lot
of gut trauma yeah maybe but they're
just gonna what they're gonna do is
they're gonna try and find some want to
affirm them right and then they'll just
be like please tell me I'm right they'll
say you're right but I don't think those
people are happy I know that state of
mind when people are like please just
put me back in the Pod but it really
it's not like a blissful happiness State
those people they want more and when
they realize there's more when when you
control your own reality that I think
it's much more enjoyable for people and
they do seek that out when they when
they know it's available you know uh
considering I I'd be willing I'd be
willing to State I bet you'll see other
correlations in this way because and
this is just my speculation the people
who are scared enough who want like the
people who are not worried and didn't
get vaccinated probably went out and
went outside so I'm I I bet you could
find a correlation between people who
are vaccinated and the amount of vitamin
D in someone's system or people who are
vaccinated probably stayed inside and
it's not just because of fear it's
because people in New York more likely
to be vaccinated Than People in West
Virginia West Virginia you're in the
middle of nowhere and you're neighbors
you know a football field away so you're
just like I ain't gonna touch anything
or anybody what am I worried about you
live in New York you're in a cubicle
smashed up next to people and you can't
go eat unless you get proof of
vaccination you're more likely to be
locked inside you're more likely to get
the vaccine I bet you'll I bet you'll
even find higher instances of organic
food consumption among people who aren't
vaccinated because they're going to be
conservative people out in rural areas
who are eating like farm meat that's
like grass-fed beef and stuff like that
yeah there's a lot of different data out
there and I think there's also data
that's not being looked at and ignored
and not calculated that also should be I
see Florida making a big step in the
right direction now officially saying
that they're going to be launching
investigations they're going to be
looking into the correlations they're
going to be looking into some of the
possible big problems here uh and and
again data could be twisted and
manipulated in many different ways but
there's a lot of glaring data that does
com complicates the picture of what
we're seeing here especially when it
comes to Sweden especially when it comes
to Haiti especially when it comes to the
countries in Africa there's a a lot of
questions that should be asked here
there should be more data there should
be more investigations and the only
people doing them is is a state of the
United States it's only Florida doing
these investigations come on we could do
better the truth matters here at the end
of the day we should be investigating we
should be getting the data we're not
which is uh an absolute shame have you
been involved in any of these
investigations look I mean we have some
investigations about the communications
between the government and some of these
private entities that we've been
undertaking that we started when Jin
saki sat at the White House Podium last
summer and said hey we've been
collaborating with these tech companies
and we're flagging this information
disinformation but in terms of the the
the side effects of some of these things
and in some of the you know being at
increased risk of myocarditis and all of
these other issues are things that like
it's great that the State of Florida is
doing that that is the kind of thing
that any objective good government would
do is you search out the truth
you're not afraid of the truth you ask
the questions and you follow the line to
to its logical conclusion thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time